good morning John a few weeks ago I was
on an airplane sitting next to a young
woman maybe 23 years old over the course
of the flight talking to her I
discovered that she does this flight a
lot in the last two years she's taken
this same flight a hundred and fifty
times she didn't like the flying she did
it for her job and her job she didn't
seem to like that much either but she
gotten a degree so that she could get a
good job and it had worked and now she's
working in a company where there are
opportunities for advancement but not
unless you have more than five years of
experience and as miserable as spending
this much time in the middle seat in
coach sounds to me she was fine she was
happy she was working her butt off doing
a job that she didn't find that
interesting but she wanted a good life
and she was willing to wait for it John
I present to you an American millennial
universally ridiculed as entitled and
self-centered but in fact understanding
the world in deeply different ways than
previous generation with new and unique
pressures on their identity and tasked
with dealing with problems unlike
anything our economy and our country and
our world has ever seen during this
week's recording of dear Hank and John
you told me about an article you wrote
for the World Economic Forum entitled
why the word millennial makes me cringe
and I immediately ran to go read that
article as soon as we were done
recording because yeah the word
millennial totally makes me cringe among
a ton of good points you making this
article you mentioned that the word
millennial was not assigned to
themselves by themselves it was assigned
by baby boomers was then later
popularized in articles and op-eds by
other people who weren't Millennials
that generally did one of three things
one made sweeping generalizations about
the most diverse group of young people
in American history - complains that a
young person was acting in a way that
they did not expect them to or 3 gave
other generations anxiety about what
these unknowable snake people are doing
to America so basically one group of
people created a term for another group
of people and then use that term to talk
about how scary they were and belittle
them and make fun of them yeah that's
gonna make some people cringe of course
the original definition of millennial
the creation of the word was separate
from all this other like let's use that
term now to talk about how weird young
people are but it does not change that
has happened and continues to happen and
it's a talk yeah there may have been a
time when America was homogenous enough
to intelligibly talk about generational
trends but I think that time is kind of
passed like the idea that Millennials
are the first generation to have grown
up with the internet blindly ignores the
fact that there are still young people
in America who
have access to the Internet and in
general these conversations tend to
replace the reality of the young
American with like the kind of young
American that people who have opinions
professionally tend to interact with all
this kind of makes me cringe a little
bit but additionally we so rarely talk
about the actual challenges that young
people in America face right now both
practically and existentially many young
people these days have been told that in
order to be valuable these days they
need to be everything they need to not
just find a good job but to find a good
job that is also extraordinarily
impactful and meaningful while they're
doing that they might as well also find
themselves in a perfect relationship and
eat ethically and become a homeowner and
pay off their student loans now I don't
want to be mad at anybody for any of
these things I'm happy to cringe but for
the most part these people are just
trying to get clicks is what it comes
down to what previous generations worked
really hard to make life better for me
than it was for them and I really do
believe that's the case whether that's
the fact that gay people can get married
or that I can get all of Buffy the
Vampire Slayer and the rest of Netflix
for just $7.99 per month or that cars
are much less likely to kill people now
while solving problems they also created
problems and also just put a tremendous
amount of pressure on the upcoming
generation to expect more of themselves
and of their lives that's not the
easiest thing to deal with not least
when things aren't turning out as
planned and it's very strange to me that
one of the chief complaints of the older
generation this generation that worked
so hard to make life easier for their
kids is that young people these days
have it too easy especially when it's
increasingly clear that they don't John
I'll see you on Tuesday